[Music]
redress I'm saying a safe house in Paris
why would I need a safe house
embarrassed should things at some point
go terribly wrong it's good to have a
place to go you know for a cup of tea
my brother's my sisters the clock is
ticking fast
my dream we who live forces before last
the moment has come to take our rightful
place
and in a world where we Wizards were
free
join me
who died the wizarding nan visiting
worlds have been at peace for over a
century
Windell world wants to see that peace
destroy you want me to hunt him down to
kill him
[Music]
dunwood oh why can't you go I cannot let
the guys crinkles Oh
it has to be here
you don't suffer from motion sickness
see I don't do well on boats he'll be
fine
Jenny why I admire you Nick
you do not seek power
you simply asked me is the thing right
[Music]
the times coming
when you have to pick a side
I don't do science
what are you gonna do looking for
something
ught you never met a monster you
couldn't love
let's take
that's her brother I think that might
have been the best moment of my life
[Music]